FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi, everyone.
Welcome I'm so grateful that
I get to host to Adam today
at Google.
And I just wanted to give
a little bit of intro.
Adam has over 20 years
of combined experience
in informal education.
First, building successful
creative business ventures,
and then applying the same
entrepreneurial spirit
within the nonprofit sector.
As the Director of Global
Studios at the Exploratorium,
Adam is responsible for
furthering the museum's mission
of transformative education
by building partnerships with
and then providing creative
services to institutions
around the world.
For five years prior
to his current role,
Adam was the Director
of Exhibit Development
at the Exploratorium.
Prior to that, Adam was an
award winning toy inventor
and founder of two successful
educational toy development
and manufacturing companies.
Adam also moonlights as a
mechanical artist creating
large kinetic
contraptions that attempt
to capture the whimsy of
his earlier toy creations.
Adam holds a BA from Brandeis
University with concentrations
in music and physics.
So welcome Adam to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM TOBIN: So
thank you so much.
It's really good to be here.
As I was preparing
for this talk,
the first thought I
had is this is easy.
I have so much to talk about
with the Exploratorium.
I can't wait to get
up there and share.
And then I got afraid,
because I realized
I have so much to share
and so much to talk about.
There's no way I'm going to fit
this in in the time allotted.
And I kind of found
a happy medium.
I realized, OK,
I'm going to find
a focus for how we talk
about the Exploratorium
and the breadth of our work.
There are several members
of my team here today.
So if they all jump up and
start waving their hands,
that means that I'm
taking too long.
And I'll try and
find a way to start
moving through all the
material we have to share.
Before we talk about
the work that we
do all around the
world, I think it's
important to be grounded first
in what the Exploratorium is,
who we are, and a little
bit of our history.
Many of you, particularly
those of you in the Bay Area,
will know the
Exploratorium and as
a place that has interactive
and hands-on exhibits.
That's just the
tip of the iceberg.
What many people don't know is,
indeed, the breadth and impact
of the Exploratorium as an
institution over a 45 year
history.
Some facts, we've created over
1,000 interactive exhibits.
They are used in 80%
of the science centers
all around the world.
We estimate around 200
million visitors a year
are using these
exhibits and programs.
And that's probably a
conservative estimate.
We have a website that has
11 million hits per year
with 50,000 pages of content.
We were named as one of the
most influential nonprofits, one
of the 12 most
influential non-profits,
of the last half century.
So there is so much going on at
the Exploratorium that puts us
in a position to work with
the wider world in the way
that we do.
So starting with a
little bit of history,
the Exploratorium
was founded in 1969
by Frank Oppenheimer, a
brother of Robert Oppenheimer.
And they worked side by side
on the Manhattan Project.
Frank was a lifelong educator
with a passion for education
and had notions about
creating a way of learning
that was hands-on,
interactive, learner-driven
and felt there was a need
to transform education
as we knew it.
Before the Exploratorium, if you
were to go to a science center,
it was largely artifact-based.
It was a place that you would
see the artifacts of science
or the history of science.
So the way we think of
science centers right now
is a place where you put
your hands on experiments
and authentic phenomena
by and large didn't exist.
And the Exploratorium
played a critical role
in creating what we now know
as the informal science center
movement.
Our original home was at
the Palace of Fine Arts.
The famous story is in 1969, one
day they just opened the doors.
People came in, and the
museum was declared open.
About two years ago, we moved
to our new location, the San
Francisco waterfront
on the Embarcadero.
It was an incredibly
transformative time
for the institution and
in many ways directly
relates to the ways in
which we started interfacing
with the wider world.
We're more centrally located.
We started thinking more
broadly about the way
in which we partner with people,
the way in which we approach
content, and even
the types of content
sets that we are
able to explore,
not to mention the fact
that is significantly more
accessible for those
of you who know where
the Palace of Fine Art is.
It's out in the edge
of San Francisco
by the Golden Gate Bridge.
I strongly suspect that a
strong portion of visitors
who tried to get to
the Exploratorium
ended up on the
Golden Gate Bridge.
And now, we're on
public transportation.
We're more accessible to a
wider variety of communities,
including the South
Bay and East Bay.
What makes the Exploratorium so
special and one of the reasons
it's had the impact it
has is its approach.
And I'd actually like to take
a moment to talk about some
of the core elements
of our approach.
And the first and perhaps
the most important
is that we have a deep
pedagogical underpinning that
is about inquiry-based learning.
And simply put, that means
that it's learner-driven.
You form your own questions.
You create your own experience.
You create your own pathways.
You create your own interest, as
opposed to somebody telling you
this is the thing
that you're studying.
This is the thing you're
supposed to be learning.
These are the questions that
we expect you to answer.
This is one of our
most famous exhibits.
It's a turntable exhibit.
And basically, it's a rotating
table with a bunch of objects
that you place on it and spin
and observe what happens.
There is no sign.
There is no explicit content.
And yet, it's about engagement.
It's about play.
It's about hands-on an
understanding of the universe.
Should you choose, then,
to explore content,
obviously there's an
awful lot of physics
that's going on
below the surface,
enough to keep a
classroom or even
a university student occupied
should you go that direction.
We believe in
authentic phenomena.
So the exhibits on the
Exploratorium floor,
they're not models.
They're not simulations.
They are the real phenomena.
And that dates all the
way back to our founding,
where exhibits started off as
props, as experiments that you
actually get your hands on.
And this is an exhibit called
water drop photography, where
you can time how long it
takes for a water drop
to fall into a cup of water.
Then you take a picture.
And you can time where the
water droplet is in its journey
when you take the picture.
There's also
unexpected phenomena.
If you were to look inside
the droplet of water,
you see the lens.
And you see the
upside down image.
Again, you start with play and
interactivity, not the lesson
about optics and lenses.
Art and science is
another fundamental part
of the Exploratorium
core approach,
that we believe that the
processes of discovery of art
and science are very similar.
And the beauty of
natural phenomena
and an artistic approach
provides a rather
profound toe-hold for learners.
So this is a picture inside
the new Exploratorium.
And the last fundamental
aspect I would touch on right
now is that of accessibility and
the power of creative engines
and a sense of perpetual,
constant prototyping.
This is our shop, which is
very unusual for museums,
is right next to our floor.
There's only a short pony wall
in between visitors and machine
shop tools.
And that was how it was
in the old building.
And that is how it is
in the new building.
It didn't have to be that way.
But we insisted that
it be so in large part
to demonstrate the fact
that there is no magic.
Here is where the Exploratorium
and is being created.
And those who are creating
it have direct access
to the floor and our constantly
testing out their ideas
on our floor.
We don't presume to get an
exhibit right or an experience
right until we have
prototyped it significantly.
I'll quickly show a
few of our galleries.
This is our central gallery.
It's probably the most similar
to the old Exploratorium,
where you'll find classic
exhibits on light, optics,
perception, listening.
And if you look, it's actually
a rather understated building.
It's a beautiful building.
But the focus is on the
exhibits and the experiences,
not so much the design
and the space around it.
The new building
also gave us a chance
to explore new content
areas, including
sociology as a content set.
This is an exhibition on
the science of sharing.
We have an east gallery
that's about biology
and natural systems.
And because of our new
location, if right now you
were to zoom into this
picture and look to the west,
you would see the
skyline of San Francisco.
And if you were to
look to the east,
you would see the bay and
all the natural surroundings.
So we created an
observatory, which
is a place where you can,
well, observe what's going on
and try and make sense of what
a rather complex system is
the intersections perhaps
of natural and human
made phenomenon.
We also have a large
outdoor campus.
Outdoor exhibits
are not new to us.
But to have space
on our own campus
where we can be exploring
outdoor surroundings
was a wonderful opportunity
of the new building.
So we began creating
experiences outside.
This is an anamorphic bench.
Anamorphosis is the
way in which an image
is adapted, mutated if you
looked in a curved surface.
So we reversed it and
put the mutated image
in the real world.
And if you look on the cylinder,
you see a rectangular bench.
We created a mobile
camera obscura.
There are rickshaws going
up and down the Embarcadero
in San Francisco.
So again, authentic
phenomena, there's
a periscope that
comes out the top.
And this is indeed a
mobile camera obscura
out on the Embarcadero.
Now I've been talking
a lot about exhibits.
But as I said
before, that is just
part of what the Exploratorium
is, an important part.
But we are also
learning designers.
We also teach professional
educators all around the world.
We have trained
thousands of teachers
in the fundaments of
inquiry-based learning.
And we take the same
approach to exhibits,
and we apply it
using found objects
for classroom exercises.
We're also a cultural center.
So the Exploratorium benefits
from being in San Francisco
immensely.
In large part, it is
who we are, the fact
that we were born here.
This is an example of an after
dark event in the evenings.
It's just adults.
And it's scientists, and
lectures, and artists.
And it's actually
quite an event.
You can have as many
as 5,000, 6,000,
7,000 people in an evening.
It's all adults.
And it's a much different
kind of experience.
But it shows the
power of community
and the type of convening
space the Exploratorium can be.
We also try to be
fearless whenever we can.
Some of you who have
been to Burning Man
will recognize El
Pulpo Mecanico.
This was actually its final
performance, if you will,
and part of our on the
move from the Palace
of Fine Arts to the piers.
And this was a group
called the Obscura Digital
at our opening that projected on
the facade of the Exploratorium
these wonderful images in
a project called Emergence.
And it was something you can
see up and down the Embarcadero.
Now, I'm here to talk
about our global impact.
All of this has
been San Francisco.
So how do you take
this and apply it?
How do you take this
and make it extensible
for the rest of the world?
This Exploratorium
has a long history
of working with partners
all around the world.
And it started out
by and large with us
reproducing our exhibits
that we were so famous for.
In 1985, IBM approached
the Exploratorium
about reproducing our exhibits
for a new gallery that
was opening in New York.
It's not something we had done.
It's not something
we thought about.
And we said, of
course, we'll do that.
And that was the
beginning, the genesis,
of a way in which
not only were we
an inspiration to
institutions around the world
and copied by institutions
around the world,
we started formalizing
partnerships with them.
That is the genesis of what
has become Global Studios.
Global Studios is a new name.
It's an outgrowth
of that work we've
done over the years in exhibit
fabrication and replication.
And there are a few
key aspects that
make our relationship successful
and have allowed us to grow.
The first is we'd
like to be as far
upstream in the creative
process as possible.
We don't like to just
reproduce what we've done.
We like to have an understanding
of the unique and individual
needs and circumstances of
anybody that we work with.
We like to bring our
intellectual capital
to bear and draw from as many
people within the Exploratorium
as possible and make it a
two-way learning street.
We don't presume, again,
to have the answers.
So for us, one of the great
benefits of the work we do
is not only are we
disseminating or sharing,
we're learning and bringing in.
And let me continue on and
talk about three projects
that I think are exemplars of
our core approach for the wider
world.
The first is a partnership that
we have with Tubitak in Turkey.
Tubitak is an analog to our
National Science Foundation
in the United States.
A number of years ago, they
decided in a rather bold move
that they were going to
create science centers
in every province in Turkey.
So that would be
81 science centers.
The government earmarked a
substantial amount of money.
And one of the
first Science Center
was in a province
called Kocaeli.
Kocaeli, if you see Turkey
up here, is east by southeast
from Istanbul.
And the center, the capital of
Kocaeli is a town called Izmit.
So the museum was going to be
created in an old paper mill
factory.
It's a really cool building.
And the way we
partnered with them
was not necessarily
just to create a museum.
We actually expanded
our partnership
to include professional
development capacity
building, design, master
planning, and of course exhibit
fabrication.
So there's going to be a series
of these pictures, you know,
where somebody's
looking at a drawing.
And they're pointing,
and it looks like they're
having important thoughts.
This is the first.
But around the table
is members of Tubitak,
members of the municipality
from Kocaeli, and our own team.
And we started off by
taking a 20,000 foot
view of what they were trying
to accomplish from a science
objective perspective.
And we began laying out
what kinds of experiences
would fit naturally
within their museum.
Now, I include this
picture, because part
of the work we do
all around the world
means we have to
respond to the rhythms
and tempo of our partners.
We were just having
a conversation
earlier about how we
tend to move slowly
at the Exploratorium.
Well, other projects tend
to move a lot more quickly.
We had to design this entire
museum in three months right
at the time that we were moving.
So we created because
Kocaeli sweatshop.
And in this room were
about 10 engineers,
designers, education
professionals,
all working pretty much around
the clock to try and meet
what was a government deadline
in order to open their museum.
That led, of course, to lay out
and plan for the museum broken
out by content set,
creating 3D models of what
the experience would look like.
And I think it's also
important to point out that,
as I said before, it wasn't just
about creating an experience
and transplanting it.
It was about the intersection
of cultures and human capital.
So we created a professional
development program
that would accompany
the exhibits
and designs we created,
the experiences we created.
And we did trainings
both at the Exploratorium
and over in Kocaeli Turkey.
There were trainings about
how you might facilitate
the exhibits, how you
might scaffold them
and do broader
learning experiences,
and even workshops on the
nature of the organization
and how you might create a
viable sustainable institution
both here and in Turkey.
And you can see
here these are some
of the classic
Exploratorium activities.
This is the cow eye dissection.
And I always liked this
picture, because it shows
a sense of play and wonder.
It's very easy to turn this
into a mechanical process.
And it's very easy to get
into layouts and designs.
But the truth in the end
is it's about affect.
And it's about the
wonder and the joy
that comes with these
kinds of experiences.
And if the staff
doesn't have that,
if the culture
then it's awfully hard to
translate that to visitors.
So a big part of our
intersection of cultures
and the professional
development we do
is providing the opportunities
for that level of inspiration.
We also sent a team over to
Turkey to build out a shop.
It was our hope from
the very beginning
when we were doing the master
planning that we would help
them build the capacity
to develop and create
and maintain their own exhibits.
So we sent over a
team that started
refurbishing a number
of exhibits on site
in Turkey working
side by side with
their Turkish counterparts.
This was the opening of the
museum a couple months ago.
And as you can tell
by the picture,
it's a deeply political event.
The government got
a chance to crow
about the investment
that they made
and the impact of
what they created.
It's a very different culture
than ours in many ways.
And the approach to
it is very different.
And I'll touch on that
a little bit later
that that had been a profound
learning experience for us.
And we have so
much more to learn
about the assumptions we
would make about our culture
and the situation we have and
the benefits we have about how
we create these kinds
of experiences, where
another culture might have
an entirely different suite
of obstacles and benefits.
This is the President
of Turkey on the walk
through with the
cohort around him.
I think you can see myself
in the background, trying
to keep a safe and respectful
distance and act casual.
And this is some of
the final exhibition.
It's actually still
being opened as we speak.
But this was the optics
gallery, dark on purpose
because of the phenomenon.
And already you're starting
to see the kind of engagement
that we hope to see and
ultimately the reason why
we do what we do.
All right.
So that was Kocaeli, Turkey.
Tinkering.
We created a tinkering
studio in Saudi Arabia.
Now I left out before one of
the most important aspects
of the new direction
of Global Studios
is we are looking to
create experiences
beyond just museums and
informal centers of learning.
This is not something
that we've created.
We firmly believe
that there's learning
happening in more and
more and more places.
That's a good thing.
There's a greater access to
tools, learning materials.
There's a
democratization of ideas.
So how do we do what we do
beyond the settings in which we
are, in theory, so comfortable?
So we created a
Tinkering program
in Al Khobar,
Saudi Arabia, which
is on the Gulf side
of Saudi Arabia.
This is an audacious
project for us.
This was not, on the surface,
an easy place to work.
And our goals were huge.
Once again, we did not want to
just create a Tinkering studio,
lift it from the Exploratorium.
This is a picture of our
Tinkering studio, which
is hands on making an
exploration of materials
on our floor.
Already in a museum
setting, this
is an innovative
approach to learning.
And many museums
around the country
are working to
figure out just how
you might do this in a
museum environment, nevermind
in a foreign country
without all of the amenities
that you would have in a museum.
And not only
creating a museum, we
wanted to create the
capacity for people
to facilitate and train and
lead the activities that
are associated with Tinkering
on their own after we had left.
Once again, in SketchUp
we created a model
of what it might look like.
The great challenge here
was, you'll see in a second,
this is happening in a
tent in a big open area.
And the activities
in Tinkering require
a certain focus
and contemplation
and a well-defined space.
So we did our best to
try and create that.
Right up here you can see
this big open patch of sand
is where the event
was going to happen.
It was sponsored
by Saudi Aramco.
And their headquarters
are here in Al Khobar.
And in a matter of
weeks what sprung up
from this patch of sand was
nothing short of remarkable.
First, the tents are erected.
And this is our truck showing
up with a Tinkering studio
in boxes.
And our tinkering
studio sat outside
in 120 degree heat and sand.
So we had to do a serious amount
of remediation in the field,
particularly for
the group that is
very particular about the
nature of their experience,
and the comfort level,
the accessibility,
the invitation that exists by
creating a space like this.
We found that just as a
side note that it was so hot
that-- are you familiar with
butcher block like yea thick?
It was cracking
that in half, which
is not supposed to happen.
So we needed a lot
of work in the field.
Now I don't know if anybody
here can read Arabic,
but I'll bet you know
that branding scheme.
It's the same in Saudi
Arabia as it is here.
There were a lot
of trips to Ikea
in trying to turn
what we had created
and what we hoped
would transplant
nicely to a tent in Saudi Arabia
into a rather warm environment.
Now as I mentioned before,
creating the physical space
was just part of the program.
We began immediately even as
we were setting up the space,
training 16 Saudi
educators that were
chosen to work alongside of
the educators there we sent.
So we sent around 8 to 12
educators in pairs of two
over the course of
this five week festival
to work alongside their
counterparts for Saudi Arabia,
thereby training them
hands-on in the facilitation
of the Tinkering activities.
This is what the tent looked
like on opening night.
And remember how I said
we're trying to focus
on contemplative activities?
Very quickly the space
turned into this.
And it was a zoo.
There were over 5,000 people
that came on average every day.
And yet, at the same
time if we zoom in,
we actually were able to create
these intimate experiences,
these moments of learning,
of inquiry, of joy.
And some of the best
pictures I've ever seen
came from this project
in Saudi Arabia.
This is actually one of
my favorite pictures.
If the eyes can
telegraph anything,
you can see the joy, the wonder,
the sense of accomplishment,
of agency.
And these are things we
worked so hard to achieve.
On the note of culture, maybe
even preempting some questions,
working in a place
like Saudi Arabia that
has such a profoundly
different culture from ours
raised all kinds of
interesting considerations
as you can imagine.
It is not our place to
judge other cultures.
And it's not our place to
say what is right or wrong.
And at the same time, there
was one very specific question
and that was gender.
So working in Saudi Arabia,
it's a much different society.
And from our perspective,
we had conversation
about how we might
approach that, indeed,
even if we would approach it.
And in the end,
from what we figured
is the impact of
doing what we do,
which should be culture
agnostic, learning, inquiry,
agency, all of these things,
we felt have their own merit
and are important.
There was one thing
that we wanted
was that both the participants
in the booth and those
that we trained would
be of mixed gender.
It was the one stipulation
that we presumed to make.
And it was OK.
So in the end, we had both
men and women in the booth.
And we had both men and women
being trained as facilitators.
One of my favorite
pictures also.
Now the professional
development didn't end just
at the beginning of the project.
We made it a point on a
daily and weekly basis
to continue discussion
and dialogue
about what we were doing and how
we were doing it with the goal
by the end of the
five week festival
transferring facilitation
of the booth 100%
to the Saudi facilitators.
And that's exactly what we did.
They're wearing some of
the Exploratorium vests.
And as you can see, by
the end of the festival,
our facilitators had
receded into the background.
And not only were they working
on facilitating the booth.
They were maintaining,
as you can imagine
in that kind of heat
and that kind of usage,
it was a constant battle, if you
will, just to keep everything
in working order.
And then on an ongoing basis.
This is just a picture
of a social media page.
We had hoped, and it
turned out to be so,
we would leave the
Tinkering studio behind.
And we would leave
behind communities
that were inspired to continue
these kinds of activities.
And the Tinkering studio
is still in Saudi Arabia.
And it's traveling
from cultural program
to cultural program with a
permanent home in a museum
in the capital of Riyadh.
And the connections that
were made between us
at the Exploratorium and our
counterparts in Saudi Arabia
continue to this day.
So the third project
I'd like to share
is right here at home at UTSF
Benioff Children's Hospital.
This was closer to home, but
also a radically new project
for us with, as you
can imagine, it's
own considerations
and constraints.
The genesis of the project
was through a group
called Child Life that
operates a learning
center within the hospital.
And they have San Francisco
unified accredited school
as well.
They had already worked
with the Exploratorium
in outreach programs and
activities for years.
So there was already
relationship.
And they were moving themselves
from their Parnassus campus
to their new campus
in Mission Bay.
We had to step back and think
about visitorship, obviously,
in a whole new way.
And we had so much to
learn about what happens
in that kind of environment.
And so many of the assumptions
that we would have going in we
were challenged with
right out of the gate.
One example is, and this may
be obvious on the surface,
but the people who use those
exhibits are not only patients.
They're siblings of patients,
they're family members,
they're people who come
to vision patients.
And there's a wide variety,
as wide as you can imagine,
of ability and presence
and state of being.
And we couldn't
cater to just one.
And in fact, that
would be a shame.
How do you make it so
different levels of ability
can experience what we create?
The other aspect of the building
is-- the obligatory design
picture.
That hospital is immense.
And there's way more opportunity
than we could possibly
do in one project
or could possibly
do before we learn
enough to do it.
So we had to look at
the entire environment
and choose where we would
start off with our experiences.
This is our high
tech database system
that's showing
exactly how we would
approach the different exhibits
and different experiences.
And then, of course,
we began sketching.
And we were looking at hallways.
We were looking at alcoves at
the edge of the museum, pieces
in the lobby, and of
course in patients' rooms.
Again, as you can imagine,
much different levels
of activity and engagement
in each of these places.
We began prototyping
with our counterparts
at UCSF, who were just
a pleasure to work with.
There was so much simpatico
about our approach to learning.
Prototyping colored
shadows exhibit.
And of course, we
got into the building
and prototyped in
the room itself.
This is an animation
station, where
you're able to move different
pieces and materials
and create your own animations.
And in the end it led
to a piece in the lobby,
which is a polarized
lenses going over scotch
tape and glass or acrylic.
And if you look at each
of these works of art,
they're participatory.
We didn't create them.
They're actually being created
by patients up in their rooms
or wherever they're
able to be working.
So it can be done
in a classroom.
It could be done in their
room if they can't move.
Even some of the more ill
and long term patients
can still be doing this
in their own spaces
and have a way of
sharing what you do
with the rest of the hospital.
And I haven't talked
a lot about the goals.
But in a setting
like this, it was
really important to
the child life experts
that it was indeed about that.
It was about life and the
fact that learning is still
continuing, and you are
able to explore and do
whatever you are able to do.
It was an incredibly
moving project to work on.
We created exhibits
and experiences
in a surgical waiting area.
A lot of classical
Exploratorium exhibits
chosen to be
contemplative in a space
that you do not want to be
incredibly active in, because
of the nature of the space.
We created a time lapse exhibit
looking out over the bay.
So there's a beautiful view
from the new Mission Bay campus
looking out over the bay.
And you can scrub through
a day at different speeds.
And it's actually
quite fascinating.
Ships are coming and going.
Weather patterns are changing.
And again, this is a way
of getting something out
of what might feel like
the alternate reality
of their confined
hospital environment,
exploring phenomena
in the real world.
We created images on the wall.
Again, something
very simple, doesn't
require a lot of
interactivity or hands-on,
but still a
content-rich experience.
We programmed the garage.
Very simple here, we created
animals and pixelated dots
for each floor of the garage.
A scope in a patient's room.
The animation station
that I just mentioned.
And the final embodiment
of the colored shadows,
which is just a wonderful
exhibit a very playful exhibit
where really the only
goal is exploring
the phenomenon of
light and optics
and transforming an
environment into a work of art.
So if you step back and
look at this body of work,
you can tell that
from our perspective
we're just scratching
the surface.
Each of these areas
we chose because we
hope that it's extensible.
We worked in one hospital.
Our hope and the hope of
the folks at Mission Bay
is that we have
created a model for how
you might work with hospitals.
In Tinkering, we
created a model for how
you might take something that
is in one sense something
so particular to
the Exploratorium
and relies on such
particular constraints
and put it out into
the world in places
where you do not have
controls on those constraints
and create broader experiences.
And our approach
to museum making,
even though they might seem
conventional on the surface,
that if you were to
create new science
centers around the world,
can we take an approach that
is as focused on
culture and learning
and affect as it is on
design and exhibits?
Over the last three years,
Global Studios breadth
has grown.
We are four times in
scope what we were before.
I know that might be another
day in the office in the valley.
But where we are,
that's profound growth.
And we see that as just
the tip of the iceberg.
So with that, I guess
I'll pause and see
if there are any questions.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Have you
ever worked with kids
to come up with ideas
for your exhibit?
ADAM TOBIN: That's
a good question.
I mean, there's two
answers to that.
The first is the way
that we prototype,
the ideas are out
on the floor and so
constantly refined, that it's
hard to say that they're not.
Right?
They're a part of
the team that allows
us to create what we create.
I didn't mention
this on the outset,
but we see our floor as
a learning laboratory,
as a research crucible.
And the visitors are
a huge part of that.
The other answer is one
of our great interests
as part of the move
was finding a way
of engaging more and more people
into our creative process.
So you could say that
x% of the Exploratorium
wasn't even created here.
We still have a ways to go.
But it's something that we're
very much interested in.
AUDIENCE: What's the minimal
level of infrastructure
required for you to do one of
these mobile Exploratoriums,
electric power,
water, et cetera?
ADAM TOBIN: That's
a great question.
My knee jerk answer is I
want to say zero, right?
If you look at the
Teacher Institute
and you look at the
snacks that they've
created that are very
lightweight versions
of the phenomena rich
exhibits that we've
created over the years, that
you could do it just with
found objects and
a table, right?
So really I think it's about the
scale and depth of engagement.
For Global Studios, for
my particular group,
we tend to be at a larger scale,
where our partners are often
institutions or
countries or governments,
educational groups that
have the resources to try
and manifest something
at a larger scale.
But we always try
and think small
when it comes to the actual
experiences themselves.
So I would hate to answer with
a threshold that would eliminate
the kind of experiences
we would want
to create in any given setting.
AUDIENCE: Do you
ever have a mandate?
So for example, perhaps
the museum in Turkey,
you must cover-- I noticed
the solar system was on there.
And that one struck me.
Because I thought how do you
tinker about the solar system?
You can't send people to Mars.
And I guess my question was
did that come organically?
Or was that kind of
part of the agreement
was that that was something
they wanted to cover,
and you had to figure out how
to approach that subject matter?
ADAM TOBIN: That's
a great question.
I mean, interestingly enough
the Exploratorium approach
tends to be content agnostic.
It's more important to
us to learning pathway
than a particular
learning outcome.
That said, that
isn't necessarily
the point of departure
for our would-be partners
and colleagues all
around the world.
And it's a question that we
have to answer constantly.
The further upstream we are
in the creative process,
the easier it is for us
to have conversations
about how important it is
to think about the learning
culture you want to create,
the pedagogical approach
to learning, as
opposed to saying
that this is about
nuclear power,
or it's about solar power.
Power comes up a lot,
particularly as you can
imagine, in the Middle East.
Some projects it's already so
woven into their expectations
that it's not something
that we could change.
And then there's a question
of how literal we have to be.
You can imagine that
if it's about power,
there are a bunch of
exhibits at the Exploratorium
that would work.
Because of the fundamental
science below it
as opposed to a didactic
demonstration of this
is solar power.
And here's a model
that shows solar power,
so you can get excited
about solar power and care
about maybe this company
that's behind the exhibition.
We're very careful about
how we choose our partners.
We don't think there's anything
wrong about having a content
outcome.
But we find that
are partnerships
work best when we are not
restricted to a predetermined
content set or at least the
embodiment of how you approach
that content set from an
experiential standpoint
if that makes sense.
AUDIENCE: I saw, as you were
going through the galleries,
you had the science of sharing.
And then I was at
the Exploratorium
and I saw a lot of the more
classic experiments that were
from like the '70s let's say.
I guess, when you're
looking forward,
what do you think the
experiments of the future
are going to look like?
Because they do kind
of feel different,
those Science of Sharing
exhibits from the earlier ones.
I mean, where do you
kind of see things going?
ADAM TOBIN: Yeah,
I mean, it's funny.
As I was joking early on
about how hard it would
be to try to get everything I
would want to say into a talk,
the Science of
Sharing areas is one
of the most interesting
areas we're working on.
And I would start by saying that
even within the Exploratorium,
when there was first dialogue
about approaching sociology
as a content set in
Science and Sharing, there
internal dialogue about
whether it could be done.
And more specifically, whether
it could be done the way
we like to do it.
More specifically,
authentic phenomena.
Right?
So how do you translate
people and sharing
into something
that would be other
than a model or a simulation
of that or a computer screen
that says here's how people
share and here's what it is?
That was our great challenge.
We've done it.
And I think we've done it well.
But we have a lot to learn.
If you were to look
at that gallery,
it has less of
that frenetic feel
that you might see in our
central gallery, where
people are bouncing from exhibit
and there's a lot of stimuli.
In the West gallery,
the Science of Sharing,
there's a little
more stepping back.
It's a little more
contemplative.
And interestingly
enough, our answer
to how you make it authentic
phenomena is the visitors.
are the exhibit.
So a great example would
be our trust fountain,
which is what we call
sip or squirt, which
is a play on the
prisoner's dilemma,
the classic sociological
phenomenon where
if two people are arrested,
they're in cahoots.
They're put in separate rooms.
And basically you say, you rat
out your friend, you go free.
You rat out your
friend, you go free.
And if they both rat each other
out, they both go to jail.
If neither one rats each
other, they both go free.
And if one rats one out,
then one goes to jail
and one doesn't, and vice versa.
So we created a
water fountain, which
is called sip or squirt, where
you can choose whether you
give a sip of
water to the person
across from you or a squirt.
And it follows those same rules,
a squirt of water in the face.
And so the nature of the
phenomena isn't so much--
or I should say, isn't only the
two people playing the game.
It's the people who are
standing around observing.
And you get into game theory.
And you get into the
actual phenomena itself
in an observational way.
So it is different for us.
I think we have so
much more to learn.
But it's also part of
our own growth in that
for it to be an
authentic Exploratorium
experience and a deep
learning experience,
does it have to look
the way it always has?
And one of the great promises,
again, of the move for us
was perhaps getting us out
of our own comfort zone.
It's one of the
reasons we presume
to be able to work
with the world in ways
that we do now,
where they don't have
the same expectations that
we would for our experience.
So I don't know where
that goes in time.
But I think the fact that we're
pushing on those parameters
and playing in that
way is actually us
being true to ourselves in
some new and interesting ways.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
if you could talk more
about what you said
about culture being
sort of a hard road block when
you're going to a new country.
How do you figure
out what you need
to change about the exhibits
for different cultures?
And how do you figure
out what's going to work?
ADAM TOBIN: Yeah.
We don't have an
answer for that one.
Yeah.
I mean, it has to start off
with an awful lot of humility.
It has to start off with
an awful lot of listening.
And it has to start off
with the presumption that
doing it our way, which
we're a very thick culture.
And we have very firm
understandings about the ways
we like to do things.
It requires a certain
flexibility in our approach.
And knowing where
we think how we
do something is very
important, and knowing
how it's going to have to
adapt or change if it's
going to be in a new place.
It's been a lesson for
us to basically say
if you can meet a certain
situation or culture part way
and find an intersection of
expectations on their side
and expectations on our
side, that's a toehold.
And that toehold is
a wonderful thing.
It may not be all
the way towards what
we would hope and want.
But you cannot recreate
San Francisco everywhere.
A great concrete example is
we're doing work in China
right now.
And China has created some
of the largest and most
magnificent museums and
Science Centers in the world.
It's staggering
the scale and speed
with which they built them.
And now there is
dialogue about how
you would create cultures
of innovation and cultures
of learning and a sustainable
R&D culture in China writ
large.
And as part of the Science
Center movement there,
what would a second generation
of science centers look like?
And the instinct will
be to go very quickly.
How fast can you
build something?
How can you have an immediate
transfer of knowledge such that
were there?
Done marvelous things
with that approach.
But that's not our approach.
We come in, and we
say, you realize
this is going to take
a really long time.
It's going to be messy.
There will not be
immediately visible results.
It's very longitudinal.
So that can't be a reason
not to work together.
And we can't come in thinking
the way we do it is right.
And if you try and introduce
speed in the absolute
or you try and introduce
scale on the absolutely,
it can't work.
We have to find a
way to say there's
merit in working together.
How do we find a
way at some scale
to introduce what we do in a
way that can demonstrate impact
faster?
Just one example.
But in the end, the truth is we
are just scratching the surface
really of understanding
how, as an institution,
we approach such questions.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Cool.
Any last message for tinkers and
makers and educators out there?
ADAM TOBIN: Wow.
I would just say that I think
it's an incredible time.
I mean, anybody who's been a
participant the Maker Movement
or education, whether
it's formal or informal,
the resources that are out
there, the accessibility that
exists, the ways
in which you can
think in associative and
interesting ways, the fact
that there are standards
changing from a government
perspective, there's
ways in which countries
can work together as
never before, it's just
an extraordinary time.
It's going to be fun to learn
over the next 10, 15, 20 years.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you so much.
This was so inspirational.
ADAM TOBIN: Thanks so much.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]